all right and we are live travis fix
your face
welcome
to the last word with little incognito
ivantas and they're very expressive ty
guy travis
uh we do it on a thursday evening
campfire let's start with how we doing
sir doing good it's a little sunnier
outside thanks to the joys of uh
daylight savings and not being in the
middle of a tornado warning that was a
fun stream this week my wife was just
like warning i was just literally ran
out left the stream on him sitting there
like in the bathroom with like two
huskies
my wife and me in like literally a
toilet closet like master bedroom and
then just the part where the toilet is
is actually under stairs so it's a
relatively safe space for because we
don't have basements so we're just the
four of us packed in there and i'm like
watching the weather and the little
radar thing go right over our house and
like please nothing happened so
yeah it's been an eventful week uh it's
been an eventful week for destiny and
all the the world of content creates
been an interesting one
but i am very addicted to elden ring
i
don't really want to play anything else
but it's like a balance of like making
content i did my raids on tuesday
but i was like i i want to play like my
wife had a yoga retreat last weekend
she's actually visiting her uh family
this weekend her mom just said surgery
so send out the good vibes first
recovery
so she's going to visit and hang out
with them and kind of you know help
where she can which is nice just means
i've got a lot of time to uh hang out
with the dogs and play altering which
works so i've got like
literally like three days of just you
know 12 hour streams or whatever i'm
gonna do until i pass out so that's
pretty much all i'm gonna be doing and
i know you've got we just got done
talking about what you've got coming up
and i'm not trying to say too much but
i'm just saying i am having a blast in
it and
to me
because i literally just got done
playing dark souls 1.
so the feel of
like a 12 year old game versus this one
you see obviously the difference but
i've also played sakura i've also played
dark souls 3. so i've kind of seen the
progression bloodborne
and i think
for them to make the leap to open world
was a risk
but just like the the quality of life
stuff that they have done in this
makes it in my mind the best souls game
especially from from fromsoft like
because the quality of life pieces when
they do when they did an open world i
was like how is this going to work
and they managed to do something well
with x and this i'm not trying to give
away too much um
and there have just been some really
really cool moments
and
the game is very good at both
challenging you
making you humbled and stuff but also
just kind of shocking you with the world
that they build so i've been having a
lot of fun i was going through just
showing somebody another content creator
i got to get him on the podcast at some
point too
um and i was just like i teleported a
couple places and i was just like all
right i'm looking at the ground and then
i panned around and looked at like one
enemy for example
and i was just like
very amazing enemy design as well and
then i teleported one other place i'm
like all right i'm gonna show you one
vista and it was just like damn damn
just
like really cool so showing up showing
it off
trying to show it off but again like you
can show it off and show somebody like
one percent you're not gonna spoil too
much shout out to necromancer
where does everyone rate 60 season 16
compared to the other destiny seasons
keep up the great work we will that can
actually be something for the end of
show because we've actually been
thinking about a couple things um but
travis what are you been up to obviously
working your tail off a bit
yeah it's gdc week so i've been uh what
gdc takes place in san francisco which
is where i'm at so i've been doing
in-person coverage it's kind of nice
good to go and
out with devs irl in the meat space nice
which has been cool yeah so um i'm
covering a bunch of unannounced games
that i cannot talk about at all because
people don't know they exist so uh i'll
i'm have a few previews going live next
week and a bunch of videos i created and
then also um
tiny tina's wonderlands my review went
live i saw that yeah yesterday
yesterday
um yesterday morning and uh that game
comes out tomorrow i gave it an 8 out of
10. i basically say it's an awesome game
if you love tabletop rpgs if you love
borderlands it's great um it also has
one
maybe the best voice acting cast of any
game it's like it's ridiculous like the
bad guys will arnett you got ashley
burke tiny tina you got uh wanda sykes
as one of the man
i thought that was right and then andy
sandberg knocks it out of the park with
his uh character he's with if you're a
fan of brooklyn nine-nine it's it's so
funny how how obviously it is it is andy
sandberg um so yeah it's it's just
really good um and the reason it's not
higher is basically just because it's uh
it doesn't really try anything new it's
like exactly what you think you're
getting when you boot up the game it's
like oh it's it's borderlands 3 with a
different skin and all that stuff so uh
but i had a lot of fun with it so that's
what i've been doing also playing a ton
of elden ring elden ring has like gotten
dangerously close to ruining my life
i cannot put that game down i stay up
till like 3 a.m and i'm just like dude i
i have to i have to work tomorrow at
like six and i just can't put the game
down so it's really bad
yeah
yeah i was like that's there's somebody
in my discord um kind of jumped in a bit
more easily he said he's got 80 hours of
elden ring in two weeks and he's
basically like i have just been
exhausted and he's like well somebody
else replied was like well yeah you have
a full-time job and then a full-time
elden ring so it's like you're doing two
for one
and it's just
it's what it's
it's the thing of
one more try one more try and then like
okay one more thing and when it when the
hooks start to get into you it's
troublesome which is it's a good thing
that a game is that good but yeah it is
definitely one that
that's why i waited that's why i was
honestly it was the perfect time for me
to wait because destiny getting into
like week five things are calming down a
little bit and then finally when i
jumped in i knew i didn't have any major
commitment story or otherwise so it was
the perfect time because yeah elden ring
is an addiction it's it's a problem but
what have you been up to cog
it's been a ton of stuff man i mean um
from game wise destiny's still got his
hooks in me i've been actually playing a
lot more pvp i've got some sick roles
i'm really loving peace of mind this the
pulse i i'm not like i i just got my
fifth one so i can craft it now i just
crafted it today i'm jealous i'm just
now here's the thing i've never i've
really rarely happened that's the way
i get a role of an archetype of a gun
that i like and i'm like ah this role is
bad right so normally i'll just vault it
and then wait for a better version it
was like elemental capacitor and
compulsive reloader and i'm like yeah
right but something told me let's just
try just to see how the gun feel and
plus i haven't played pvp in a while
yeah i'm sitting there and i'm like why
am i shredding people with this gun like
i am destroy like my kd was insane i'm
like i am not this good like what is
going on and i was really seeing it was
that gun and and i was just trying to
look at what the stats i had on and
stuff like that so i've been doing that
shout out to the team still been raiding
you know as much as i possibly can on
that front um as far as everything else
i got a chance to um shout out to
microsoft i got a chance to do the halo
screening the tv series i have i saw
that picture i have thoughts about that
my wife recently my wife recently just
got paramount plus because
she's been a joint equalizer uh so she
wanted to kind of have watch that with
that but also like her family likes to
show ghosts on there it's a comedy it's
actually pretty damn hilarious uh
basically two people move in the house
she has like some kind of accident and
can now she can see the ghosts
that are all in the house from like
different generations from like oh wow
or to like a modern stock broker but
then her husband can't and just comedy
is ensues and it's actually
i like the kind of because they've done
horror house of ghosts before but the
comedy spin on it made actually fun so
we checked that one out but i was like
hey i'll get to check out halo 2. so i
got to know here
here
here
here or here two thumbs one thumb middle
up or down
one thumb down i i think it's bad i've
seen the first two episodes i don't know
how much you've seen cog
uh yeah he's gonna see the screener that
everybody saw yeah i hate to be the
bearer of ben news oh no
oh no yeah yeah it it you know what it
is it's unfortunate for me because i'm
not even
like they're supposed to win me over
like trav is the hardcore knows the lord
knows what's going on
me i'm the champion
that's why i don't like it
right yeah
yeah it for me i'm like okay i got the
the basic gist of everything and the
longest shot of it without going too
long here because we got an amazing
guest waiting
is that you know
it sucks because the production value
for the most part looks good for the
most part right for the most part i'm
just talking about like the feeling it
looks like a sci-fi channel shows yes
yes all right i'll give you that but for
them
for halo looking decent for the most
part and i just feel the show runners
started to make some choices where
they're like yeah we don't even care
what you feel about the lore we don't
care like we're going to run this how
we're going to run it that's what that
was the comment that kind of messed up
the internet yeah yeah and the show
runners basically said we didn't pay
attention to the games we didn't
actually look at the games and everybody
went see i i actually think that's a
good thing because these are untethered
from the canon and they're doing their
own thing which i think is the smart way
to do it because you do not want to be
beholden to what's holding into the
thing and normally not to cut you
normally i'm open-minded with stuff like
that i'm open-minded with not being
letter of the law that usually is not a
thing for me the thing for me because i
don't want to spoil it is literally
halfway through the first episode they
do something and it just lost me it just
disconnected me and i didn't recover and
i think i know what you're talking about
so yeah i yeah i i actually i don't have
a problem with that either people are
complaining about seeing master chief
too early people are complaining about
the non-canon stuff and i don't have a
problem with any of that i still went in
like it could be good but as soon as i
saw like the first two episodes i was
like yeah it's not a good show it's just
separately it's not a good show the
special effects aren't good the writing
isn't that good it's just sort of the
writing
it's like it's a very campy like
not not good show yeah enough about that
fair enough yeah i was like
i'll i'll eventually maybe get there it
sounds like no yeah
yeah so let's get this show officially
started she has been waiting a bit so
let's do it how we do
welcome to the last word episode number
190
10 away from 200 is crazy rise yi
tarnished as you wander the lands
between many of you have taken your
first steps into limb grave wait
wrong game wrong podcast sorry about
that this week content creators feared
for their channels avoid 3.0 changes are
coming in hot and the difficulty rose a
bit this week to discuss an eventful
week in the world of destiny we are
joined by a very lovely lady of the
destiny community she may have started
gaming a little later than some
but online gaming is a familiar
territory for sure surely she has spent
the most time playing destiny uh nope
that title goes handily to the game of
runescape that she's been playing for
more than 15 years but her gaming skills
are no joke either whether it's
shredding a guitar hero dodge rolling
for that final boss hit in elder ring
she has earned her stripes for sure
while her time at disney has come in
phases like many of us she has a pretty
committed she's been pretty committed
since shadow keep and i think she's gone
full send with a recent three-man clear
valve the disciple and a gilded unbroken
title to prove it so let's welcome a
lover of parks and recreation agrees
heath ledger is the best joker twitter
personality that is followed by the
official kitkat account
mother of leo the lion perfect balance
to the campfire she embraces all things
hunter most of the time and one who
seems to really have quite a thing for
rolk who you'll have fi and you'll
usually find her wearing purple glasses
the one the only miss knope how you
doing
oh my god i actually love that whole
thing
hello
that was so beautiful that got me i was
like no way
hello
oh this is my second podcast so bear
with me i'm trying to like get that
social anxiety out of the way we got you
we all have it
we've just practiced for 190 episodes
but believe me i'm we're i'm part
introvert anyway so it just has kind of
come with time
well thank you for having me i'm excited
absolutely um i kind of want to ask you
like where for you it's like you know it
touched on a little bit but your kind of
gaming journey seems like you didn't
like grow up with like a controller in
your hand before it could fit but like
where did your gaming journey
actually get started and kind of what
got you into those early games that you
got into i know i mentioned a couple but
early gaming for you is definitely
different than some that we've had on
the podcast so just kind of curious how
it started and what what got you into
what you got into
so i was like mostly i think i was about
14 at the time when i actually started
to discover video games i was more into
like
um bonding with my brother you know i
have like a couple sisters but i was
never into that like makeup stuff so my
brother actually got me into runescape
at the time i think it was back in like
2007
or like even earlier than that i think
it came out in like 2001 or something so
for those who don't know what runescape
is
can you give like
high level quick overview just so some
people know what you were doing back 15
years ago
oh my god bruce keep is
i i personally still think it's a really
really good game that a lot of people
i don't think even know about
um
you do it's more
i'm trying to like think of a game that
actually is like that
it's a it's an mmo though okay it's a
really really nice uh rpg
um so if you're into those types of
games it's it's actually really fun
there's a lot to do you have like quests
you have skills you level up and
you can spend like hundreds of hours
into that game but back
back in that day or back in like 2000
whatever like the graphics were a little
bit like wonky
so i don't know if people would actually
like that or enjoy that now since it's
like 2022 people like
beautiful graphics and stuff
but it's something that you can like
stick your like you know time into and
actually enjoy the game
um there's not really much to it it's
just it's just an rpg just a regular one
because back in the day it really wasn't
too too much
but i enjoy it still i go back to it
from time to time
nice nice so from there like where where
did the transition and gaming start as
far as what other games i know i know
you mentioned well at least you
mentioned as far as like guitar hero
which is very unique and cool was there
any other games as well along the way
that kind of caught you more interested
in the game
i remember playing on gamecube
okay and my favorite game on gamecube
was mario party 4. oh i played i played
a couple of mario parties back then but
mario party 4 is like what's stuck in my
brain
a little bit so what you're saying so
what you're saying is that you fought
your brother yeah i was gonna be like i
was like glad they were a family because
you could lose weight and my brother
were very competitive and still are
um
but back then though he would challenge
me to guitar hero
actually he me and him on expert were
hard we would always just i think it was
a guitar three that we like mostly
bonded with but nice yeah three was a
good one i played that for a bit
my sister and i actually enjoyed mario
party um more than that but she recently
got back into gaming and stuff um she's
in the cuphead i'm not into covering
it it gets super mad for me
i was like between her playing cuphead
and you playing elder you guys are not
shy for a challenge i'll give you that
no
actually that's the elgin ring is my
first ever souls game
so it's a little a little different from
what i'm used to because i'm into like
mmos and like rpg or like you know first
person shooters actually is what i
usually aimed for yeah so like back then
i was like
uh like call of duty call of duty um for
i think was my first ever call of duty
game
um that was actually one of my favorites
and then i got into like black ops 2
black ops 3 but i was into zombies like
i'm a big fan of treyarch zombies
zombies get classic and i have a tattoo
of the four perk bottles emoji perk
bottles okay okay yeah i was i was big
into it i still am but they haven't
really made anything besides i think in
vanguard
i'm gonna say yeah we may not even what
are we getting this year modern warfare
2 probably
yeah so i'm not really big into like
their first person shooters anymore
lately but
yeah i'm a big zombies fan as well um
i know i was into wii sports a little
bit
i think everybody played wii bowling for
two oh tennis sorry
i like the boy too well i was like if
you had wii and you had people that ever
got into it the bowling was always fun
yeah definitely that's actually uh
pretty good at that one too
nice no doubt try what you got for
i'm trying to think of whatever you
played
that was mostly the majority
of like the big games i played um
since my like video game journey
it's nice so what um
so you said you played
call of duty and other first person
shooters is that what got you into
destiny 2 or destiny 1 i'm not sure when
you started but is it was it just the
fact that it was a first person shooter
that intrigued you or was there a moment
where it clicked and you decided that
you were going to stick with it for
longer than you know a typical shooter
game or
how did that start
i think i actually
um
i think i started actually in destiny 1
but i didn't play enough of it to
actually be invested into it so i think
i played maybe 20 30 hours
um
so i think it was the graphics and like
the gameplay that i saw in like trailers
that would
look intriguing i guess you could say
yeah um
but when i played it
it was like i didn't have anybody to
play with
so i think i had to stop at this point
d1 you actually had to have people yeah
for sure um so i think i stopped after
like
pretty much hitting a wall at that point
um i didn't know anybody that played it
so i stopped i think that was in like
what year was that 2014 i think is one
of the first launches yeah
crazy it's been that long i know it's
crazy too long ooh and then we got two
destiny 2 in 2017
17 yeah and i got back into that so i
did the same thing pretty much and like
did like maybe 30 40 hours of that
and then i don't know it i guess it just
dropped off for me
at a certain point i don't really
remember but after that i actually got
it to fortnite and so i took all my time
into fortnite after that so
but
uh the end of 2019 i think when shadow
keep came out um
i started back up and i was like you
know what i actually really enjoyed this
like i had people to play with at the
time
a couple friends yep and then that's
what pretty much started it like i had i
actually had fun i actually learned like
leviathan for the first time like with
other people
and i guess that just stuck with me and
i've been playing it
i'm at like almost three thousand hours
now since then so
yeah you got a you're a few minutes in
the game but that is
that is destiny's experience in the nut
in a nutshell for a lot of people
because a lot of people try by
themselves don't know what's going on
especially the new player experience now
is all sorts of questionable
and they can fall off because they don't
have those groups to see other content
kind of get them hooked and as you said
you got to play leviathan you got to
know a little more a couple pointers
from friends along the way and then all
of a sudden then you can kind of get
over that big hurdle that is kind of
getting into it and then when you do
it's nice to get hooked but it there's a
bit pretty big hump to get over to start
actually getting into this game because
otherwise yeah i could definitely
especially d1
yeah and then start of d2 when you
didn't have like random roles and a
little bit of leviathan but if you
didn't have the raid there was a there
was only some there was no replayable
campaign stuff like there is now like
yeah it was it makes perfect sense like
where you kind of fell off and then why
friends got you back in so
yeah
i'm sorry i got no good
no i was gonna say it was a good game i
just didn't it just didn't catch for me
you know not a lot of games do
but i at least try like now to give it a
chance you know
i don't want to go back and like miss
the whatever i miss back then like doing
like i've never done a d1 raid besides
vlog but that came back in d2 so i got
the chance to do that
so i missed the chance to experience
that raid for the first time and i i
don't want that anymore i don't want
that fomo you know cafe cafe ah the
destiny fomo
so yeah let me let me ask you this
though so what about like
you know obviously you went away came
back then d2 you kind of went away came
back this time you got friends you're
playing it you join it so like
what was the moment
for you when it okay
it has its hooks on me
i'm staying with destiny i love this
game was it like a specific activity was
a specific raid like what was that
moment when you knew okay yeah
i'm in
all the way so to speak i think i don't
think it was leviathan
even though that was my first raid like
i liked it i enjoyed it but i didn't
really catch my eye but i think when i
first did scourge of the past
um i actually i actually really really
liked it because i it was still it was
it was still like really i think popular
back in 2019 i forgot when it was
released but
i really enjoyed that rate that that
would probably be my my favorite rate so
far i only done it a handful of times
like maybe 30.
but i don't know just the atmosphere
even though i'm not big on like fallen
you know but yeah
just the way it is like i really like
insurrection prime as a raid
boss pretty simple but besides rolk
obviously but
clearly based on your profile yeah
we know how much you like we're going to
get into that
exactly
i think the whole community is actually
not just me i promise
i gotta ask you like i i know i'm going
off asking them because no no what is it
about rogue like i i need to know but
educate the old man that's his old
grumpy gamer
yeah like the walk the way he doesn't
care he gets too close i'm gonna give
you the boots
uh it's just that kind of he just kind
of sits up there he's got his hand
tucked behind his back and he's just
he's almost got like that like lean
against the wall kind of like swallow of
death bad boy yeah he's kind of like the
best yeah he's like the darkness bad boy
of destiny for whatever reason that's
probably a bad description but
i still think it's hilarious so the
ladies is feeling this nope this is what
it is
i don't know i can't really just i can't
really say like she said she said i'm so
messed up
like the first time i saw him i'm like i
like this one i like it
i like it picasso
yeah he's got he's got big darkness
energy
i like that one i'm
he's got you know he's got nice calves
you know good he's got nice legs he's
got nice legs yeah good legs
a nice
d energy for sure if you don't feel like
saying
see that's what i was trying to avoid
thanks buddy
so so pride all right so prior to rock
was there anyone in contention for the
the raid boss defenders you know ladies
meow title like wha what was going on
before rogue i'm curious
he's got the body for it for sure
he got he got deceptive little you know
the cup
he's been a bit too opulent a little too
obvious he's got he's got enough chins
to go around man clearly
so so pro pride wrote got the title now
no but i want to know like was there any
other destiny characters that you like
really
yeah the uh pit of paracetamol yeah
big boy she like beef okay that's true
everybody freaking soul back but i liked
him for a while really is cool even
though he's like a like a baby oryx
like he's like a fired crota he looks
cool
i still wish we could get a set of armor
that looked like him i would never take
it off
the green yeah
well just like his like molten look was
always very very cool oh my gosh i just
want to say that i actually like that
oh yeah that's true
i think this is a new segment trap i
think we whenever we have female guests
we have to ask these questions these are
the important questions the community
needs to know like who are the sex
symbols of that's like we need to know
clearly we don't know what's going on
out here i think it's different with me
because i'm not actually like interested
in like real people like shacks i'm into
like the creatures you know
so like rules like in real
life
so what we're not going to talk about
today is the con the conventions that
nope goes to but that's a different
discussion
[Music]
let's get it no actually i wanted to i
was like for a ridiculous icebreaker i
was actually listening to defining duke
and you guys had a hilarious like
question come in and it's not the
question itself it was
how you and him went back and forth
about it and it was you gotta get rid of
one
yeah that one was funny and also if that
pic was that picture with you just like
you're like
so okay for chat and for
for us you got to get rid of one of
these indefinitely so you can no longer
eat this food
and let me see if i remember all of them
burgers
wings
yes fries and pizza
wait i have to keep one you know you get
rid of one forever so you can have three
but one goes forever pizza
you get rid of
pizza oh
she's cold
she got that big darkness in his yes oh
my god a little bit just a little bit
yeah i don't think pizza i'm not a big
pizza fan honestly i don't know
that's too much
destroyed statue of pizza would look
good on a pyramid ship yeah
i think so
through all the ruins of different
species
one of the things the darkness took was
pizza as long as they keep the chicago
deep dish i'm good
debate you guys have gone too
you guys are about to be like buying
each other pizzas cross country just to
prove which one's better to prove the
other one's better
i just feel like there's no one on the
side of chicago deep dish like i i feel
like it's a it's
it's like a one-sided fight you guys are
punching down
like this yeah they just don't want to
go away they don't want to go away and
they they they keep acting like what
they have is considered pizza and i'm
like it's not even the same
classification like you're something
else
travis where are you at on this one
which one do you get rid of
it depends if wings just count as like
the you know covered in sauce
greasy wings because if it's those i
think that's an easy choice just get rid
of the wings but like if you're if
you're saying if it's all chickens that
i can't fried chicken then i would die
like that
exactly
and they're talking about like the kind
you get at a bar that are covered in
like you know sauce or something yeah
hot sauce ever like i would get rid of
those for sure but 100 yeah i can't i
can't
fried chicken is too
like on a waffle man
that's cool you know waffles you just go
oh see i got another guy rook dry rub
wings are better than sauced wings
okay
yeah yeah so when people say wings
usually they're talking about the soggy
wet wings and i would get rid of those
for sure yeah like those are trash yeah
if it's if it's
i'll see if it's wings
i can go without now if you say you
don't get like chick-fil-a fried chicken
or if it's just all chicken i can't get
rid of chicken that's like too important
for sure
but if it's if wings go like no pizza
burgers and your discussion about fries
was interesting because you were fries
is that right yeah i said fries good
girl and but and you said it's crazy i
was like yeah i was like tough i like
fries too
but as you said some are good some are
bad but i was like if it's good fries
just destroy his wings in a heartbeat
for me if chicken
if the idea of chicken is still like if
it's just wings
yeah wings can go because you can have
like i can have chicken tenders i could
have a grilled chicken sandwich like
that stuff's still there
too many fries are good and especially
like yeah it's like
i've had some good fries anyway it was
just hilarious so i was just kind of
curious so everybody was on that one but
it was just you and him going back and
forth on it got me cracking up the other
day this week it was this week it was
soda
oh
what is it we were forced because we
don't even drink soda anymore and it was
like okay well what did you drink
um it was
we we did
the favorites when we used to
and i think i had my top threes like
mountain dew
um
it was the second one i forgot what the
second one was but and i think i put in
oh um oh pepsi over coke that was
another one um
yeah
you know what it is you're a hipster
you're like you're you're the proto
hipster you just want like everything
that is unpopular as like your jam i i
love things that people don't like
you don't like things that are hugely
popular yeah yeah i tried to not
gravitate no that's accurate that's
that's that's three questions what's up
nope what's your question
i i do that too cog oh but i do kitkats
or reese's oh
now you're acting up i'm i'm all about
kitkats and like my love kitchen she
knows that but like each year i do a
poll on twitter and i'm like yeah it
makes everybody look like we're gonna
win that poll i love you know
her picture is she is followed
officially by the kitkat account and i'm
pretty sure you lost your mind that
explains
for me kit kats are good reese's just
it edges it out personally like they
know that's greasies are okay right so
they have a different variety
but kitkats are on a whole different
level have you seen the japan flavors
there are some interesting things more
yeah there are some interesting ones
like i have a box full of like there's
apple there's um like chocolate there's
coffee like there's a whole like there's
lemon strawberry with reese's you don't
you don't have a lot of that you got
reese's you got i mean yeah they're all
variations like a fast break is actually
really good i just don't see those very
often
um
and there's different variations but
yeah it's like there are many more
flavors with kitkat i will give you that
and i've had some good ones but like
just the og kitkat versus the og like
cup
of reese's cup like that's
that i'm going to lean re that'll get
that i gotta go races
no it's understandable i do like reese's
though but i like i like i like the raw
people up with it
yeah i like reese's pieces i like i like
them small don't have peanut butter m
m's
yes those are good
you haven't cog
no i've never honestly take a reese's
pieces and make it a little better
there's a little more chocolate and a
little more peanut butter and honestly
like
peanut butter m ms just like they beat
reese's pieces when they came when i
tried them so honestly
to me they're better
really bigger too i think i think
reese's pieces are more like smooth
like
that's my biggest problem with chocolate
peanut butter m ms is that they're kind
of like
you can tell this wasn't what they were
gonna make first right like this was
just a variation this is like this is
like the fourth product they came out
with was like reese's pieces you can eat
that it's like it's like drinking candy
baby
i do like this piece
they're good but man it's just like the
i don't know the balance between it's
like i used to like the wendy's spicy
chicken sandwich but then when
chick-fil-a came out it wasn't their
first one but they they refined it they
mastered it and then when it came out
the briefly chick-fil-a spicy chicken
sandwich oh it's amazing i'm with y'all
me you yeah
yeah that is and again what do you and i
always i do take off the pickles because
i don't like pickles
but then i forgive you i love pickles
too
yeah
that's an affront to my people yubantos
you better like
sorry
i could eat pickles by myself
i love pickles so i don't like pickles
period haven't really been from all
delis this has been done yeah
i typically don't go to delis and if i
do it's a very boring sandwich just to
get through it but no i worked at a
movie theater i like worked at a
cinemark movie theater when i was like
16 16 something like that and you know
they sell the big pickles like the big
hole pickles that you could buy dills
yeah the big hole ones and the problem
with that was like you used to like we
had to like go in the back and get one
it's like these giant tongs and it's
sitting in the bucket of pickle juice so
i literally pick it up and it slips
drops and splashes me in pickle juice
and i nearly threw up like i don't like
pickles enough and or the smell like i
can smell pickles across the table
that's the rule of year so it's like the
fact that i was covered in it that was a
very rough evening for me so no pickles
are not so good wow
the traumas of an affluent white are
just so different
i've been scared
you're like dude i nearly died tonight
calm down
man our lives have been so different
every time i tell a story i just show
them how much more sheltered my life was
than theirs every time it makes me that
much that much worse you are y'all be
the hippie you are a unique individual
brother thanks bud
[Music]
i grew up in the suburbs of dallas what
can i say so yeah absolutely this is
full of uh
we got a little off topic
but before we even get to destiny what i
kind of want to cover is
the content creator situation that
happened outside of dusty this is one of
those it's like we got hog on speed dial
for this one real quick but um yeah can
i check today i do every sunday
i'm sure
i'm sure you guys will talk about it for
sure but um
concert creators this week got scared
and honestly it's a combination of
somebody going rogue which we figured
out
and also youtube's
pretty terrible policies in the way
their systems work being as somebody who
goes rogue and basically
somebody impersonated
um kind of a brand management company
person and what they were able to do is
just start striking and it's different
like i can post a video that has
the paul mccartney song from the lost
sector in destiny
and i get a like copyright you know no
longer monetized woohoo like okay so
don't make money on that video not the
end of the world or you can mute this
part of your video and you're good now
these are like
three strikes in your channel is
terminated type strikes
and
huge content creators like astrocross
was two out of three
he had and
some of these other and there was
somebody i know who woke up with like
five an australian creator
and some of these were now previously
like maybe a month or so ago there had
been
some youtube creators that were just
uploading the soundtracks
now some people have like a fight
uh like with regards to like soundtracks
that you can't get anymore you can't buy
them anywhere you can't get them anymore
and people wanted to kind of preserve
that
but like people would take the witch
queen soundtrack and upload it to a
youtube channel for example yeah
now bungie has addressed that with the
in the twab
they basically said hey for preservation
sake if it's no longer available for
purchase anywhere and it's something you
want to do for preservation reach out to
licensing at bungie.net like emailing
and then you'll be able to do that you
just won't be able to monetize but so
it's out there so they did resolve that
one but on top of any like content
creators big ones small ones were
getting copyright strikes i was lucky
did not think but i was like
because as to cross had a twab video
scrolling through the news article
reading that got struck and we're like
is anything safe honestly we didn't know
so i don't know if somebody just had a
hard-on to go strike some of these
people
um but basically even bungie had a
couple of their
their videos and their channels get a
strike which is even weirder
so they dug into it twitter was out
there but i mean astacros posted
literally this could be my last video
video and then things were resolved i
think monday once bungie had the meeting
with the people they had to
but the bigger issue that came up is how
easily it was for that stuff to be at
risk
that was the bigger issue the fact that
somebody could portray the wrong company
get the amount of power that they had
and then ruin people's livelihoods
was
kind of terrible but also very revealing
to some of the occasional issues that
youtube
needs to refine some of their um
policies and procedures and stuff with
all of this so i wanted to kind of get
you guys takes on this if there's
anything you've seen it's like i know
cog you guys have your channel travis
you've been around enough stuff nope and
everything like i just wanted to get you
guys takes and thoughts on this one
because it was
as somebody it's like if you go
full-time content creator and you see
something in vanish that fast it's scary
you know what would you think when when
uh all the news broke and what was going
on
um
i found a little bit weird at first
because you see one one person being hey
i got a strike and it's like okay all
right something happened
you know whatever and then when you
start seeing multiples
of like so many people especially
mutuals you say like hey i got struck
and all this and that and it gets scary
because people actually like you make
money off it you know what their
livelihood and stuff like i don't
personally
have a really a youtube per se like i do
but i don't post on it
but like if that was me i would be i
would be scared obviously
um
but i don't know much about that i
didn't really invest into knowing about
it but i'm glad that they like addressed
it because i know they put out 12 today
addressing it
i didn't get the chance to read it but
i'm hoping that they you know it did a
fix right yeah most things were pretty
much
a lot of things look like they got
resolved on monday because bungie even
like cosmo tweeted over the weekend that
like 8 30 in the morning on a sunday he
replied to stuff so he was
for them being on the west coast that
was 8 30 my time so it's like 6 30 in
the morning he's replying to this stuff
we got a meeting on monday they're
taking everything into you know trying
to get all the stuff some stuff they
said they couldn't talk about because i
think it's is it lyanna's the other cred
uh community manager is that her name
leon i think
yeah she's the newest one uh she was
saying some stuff's under investigation
so we can't talk about everything as
well so i mean there was there was some
stuff going on
so
yeah it's but yeah it's one of those
things depending on because the the one
that i saw his name was like aussie halo
and he's may not be the biggest guy but
and then but esoteric on the other side
if you've ever played you've seen him
he's a beast and but like big and small
like esso has like 380 000 subs and i
think aussie halo was much smaller
both are australian creators but it was
like hey you played through this mission
and there was a cut scene in there
that's what got struck and it was
stuff that never had before which is why
it seemed so strange
yeah so that was why so what about you
were you at yeah it was crazy i remember
it because sunday we're you know live
doing lp
halfway in and i get this dm from hulk
and i'm like you know usually you know
talk but he knows when i'm live so yeah
i know whatever he had to tell me was
was important so i'm like you know you
kind of see what's going on i think you
should be aware of it i'm like i looked
i'm like really they're not i'm looking
into it i'm like doing the show and then
looking into it at the same time and
then when i seen the tweet from bife
that's when it hit me yeah cause biff
was upset and by and rightfully so like
he was i don't know how many strikes he
had at the time but he kind of was just
like look you know what is going on and
like bungie you have to get ahead of it
and i know i just calmed down and
he took the tweet down and you know and
he said it was probably a bad taste
because emotional but emotions were high
like people were thinking that their
channel was really going to be gone and
he was just like hey you got to make a
decision but you're like is it going to
be the content creators or that's going
to be what you do because no one knew
what the source was at the time right
and then the theories start running and
then you know i'm in party chats after
the fact that we're trying to figure out
i hit you up you hit me up you know we
all we all be you traveling the dms and
stuff and i'm just like bro are you okay
because when i seen the esoteric one
that's what made me nervous for you
cause i was like you know and i'm in the
astro cross one excuse me too because
ashcroft was just doing a twap i'm like
oh he does that so i'm like yo is your
channel is everything all right so as
you get more information than the funny
part chad that's the funny part you like
so all my xbox friends like god i'm
telling you
sony bro
yo they was they was like what's the
only thing that has changed and i'm like
well they're like look at the timing of
it i'm telling you they got a quiet they
don't know what they was getting into
and somebody's behind the scenes
flipping the switches and i'm like look
man i don't know we gotta wait until we
get it just in case you're curious if
some of those guys are biased or not
yeah
but in fairness in fairness
no one knew what what so if you're just
doing basic detective work what's the
only major thing that happened yeah that
was very much proven like
yeah bunchy very clearly the bungee even
came out and tweeted i think it was
sometime on sunday from their official
account it's like these are not coming
from us or our partners or anything
right there's been no direction from
bungie to do any of this north of our
party absolutely they cleared that up
but i saw the same thing running around
i'm like
yeah i was like what is going on so yeah
that as
as the weeks going on and stuff and you
start to get more information then when
i seen cross this the funny thing was
that the laugh but it was like
i could tell it really affected cross
because he put a video here like i think
it was like see at these footages it was
like a completely different game he
ain't what no smoke would distract and i
felt that i was like yo he's like bro i
cannot lose this channel you just say
like i feel like that's people's
livelihoods man you know it was serious
so i'm glad they got ahead of it i'm
glad they you know as we get into talk
about specifically what it seemed to be
the issue was but uh yeah shout out to
shout out to hulk though hogan spicy
yeah he was just going look you you know
it made it
very clear
that the terms of service
technically can be
used against you at any
time that's what i learned continue trap
yeah you're not protected in terms of
service it's actually that so i this is
actually one of the things my job
covered when i worked at ign um as a as
a suit right before i was actually oh
yeah big zd
you're still a suit which is he's
i'm still a suit but now i'm not a
creative suit you know
he's a creator
yeah which is which is that like if
you're if you're using if your business
model requires using somebody else's
content and remixing it or incorporating
it into your product in any way you
exist in the legal gray area
which is that
technically all of the stuff you're
using is trademarked and it's copy
written and it can't be used
except with explicit permission from the
uh creator or the copyright holder and
um
the only way to legally get it is to get
a license with that person to use that
and for use that property it's why um
you know uh insomniac can make a
spider-man game because they have the
license from sony and who has the
license for marvel yada yada it's like a
bunch of legal paperwork to use it and
um
basically if you're a streamer you are
breaking uh their their their terms of
service part of what they say in their
terms of service and in in their legal
protections for their property is you
will not use this
to make money and if you do use it to
make money uh we
can we can sue you and we can you know
do all this other stuff because and and
that's not on bungie that that exists
bungie should be doing it because
there's also legal precedence that even
if you're copyrighted if you don't
actually enforce your copyrights
uh then you can
this has happened before where they go
to court and they go well you know what
the property kind of belongs to everyone
now it's part of the culture so it's not
yours anymore and then then they get in
trouble if they're if they're a company
that's trying to create something so um
they have to enforce their their
protections and i think that's it's
their legal obligation to do so
but um
because streamers exist which are are a
relatively new thing the law moves a lot
slower than the real world um there's
now this entire group of people who make
money off of it and
the
cr the creators want them to be able to
use their content because
it's free marketing it helps uh spread
the word about their game all these
other reasons but they can't not in
enforce their
uh their their copyright so what they do
is they put out these
policies that say we probably won't
enforce our own copyright claim under
these circumstances and bungie has one
of those
uh and it seems like on accident they
over enforced their copyright and went
against the policy that they created but
i i think our if one thing has been made
clear by all this it's clear that like
our laws are not really up to snuff with
the way that the world works when it
comes to copyright
and that needs to change sometime pretty
soon because it's kind of crazy
if you're a copyright holder to have
this thing where you have to enforce it
but also you have to not enforce it in
order for your business to work and it
also just really sucks for content
creators now that said youtube is part
of the problem they're the ones creating
the three strikes you're out rule
they're the ones not being the greatest
at managing their platform so they also
need to revise their policies but i
think it's honestly mostly just the fact
that the law is old school and streamers
are not old school and this is just the
way the world is for for the time being
so
it's very interesting uh as somebody
who's pre-law and cares a lot about
legal stuff i
really like this sort of stuff so uh
yeah i was uh i was keeping track of it
but yeah man if you're streamer look out
cause
they're who knows what the law is gonna
be like in five ten years
yeah it's it's good to know too
yeah actually for sure
yeah it's been nice to know that it's
like it is it is a
scary gray area for anybody who does
full-time content creation especially
the ones who's literally bought houses
on their content creation like i mean
they go
big enough that they're making that much
money but it's also the point of
companies will pay these people to do
that and that will have an agreement to
it but as you said travis it's also
the marketing that they get from the big
ones but also the small ones whether
it's the guide or things that continue
to help somebody in a live service game
like destiny hey this game is going to
suck ten things to do as a as a new
player let me watch this video oh well
okay this doesn't seem quite so bad now
little things like that allow somebody
to keep in your game and now they're
still spending money in the everest
store so it is it is a balance as you
said the laws are very outdated it's the
dmca rules youtube arbitrarily has you
know the three strikes and then your
channel's deleted and you're like i
can't even like preserve what i've got
it's like maybe you can stop uploading
temp stuff definitely needs looked at
now granted bungie is large and maybe
bungie and sony with sony actually
paired with bungie now maybe they have
enough you know
wait to go talk to youtube and be like
i want to look at it but honestly even
for youtube to change something that
large i feel like it would take a long
time for them to go through set up new
policies and sync so nothing's going to
happen overnight so it is still
the fact that somebody was able to do
that could technically happen tomorrow
if somehow they did that
until
whatever happened is obviously stopped
so
but yeah anytime you boot up something
like eldering you're like well thanks
for letting me do this
i'm playing a lot of it hopefully
hopefully you're okay with that nintendo
has been was the worst when nintendo has
been forced
they're so bad
oh i even
i thought about
i can't even remember what game like
breath of the wild at one point i even
thought about an uploaded one i was like
never mind
i think theirs is intentional though no
like they're they're crazy yeah i don't
know if you guys are on the if you guys
are on press release type stuff but so
nintendo's hilarious because like 80 of
their press releases are like we want a
lawsuit against this person and you
better watch out because if you do
anything we're coming for you next
that's like and then and then like the
other twenty percent is like game
announcements it's crazy man it's like
it's like mostly them just like
threatening the world that they're gonna
sue them yeah so you try to use mario
very strange press release cadence and
and what they talk about i i it is
interesting being behind the scenes
seeing them i completely agree trav i
see those messages i'm like what is
going on that is why you don't see
unless it's probably somebody who has
like a partnership or some kind like
agreement with nintendo you won't find
much of their stuff out there because of
all those reasons like you post a random
gameplay video gone like and it's not a
strike it's usually like
just you know
you're not gonna monetize it so you're
like well what's the point so yeah
anyway and the uh the press releases are
not positive by the way it's like like
even nintendo's not trying to present
them positively like i feel like the
headline on half of those is nintendo
successfully ruined someone's life
then turned to the camera and held up a
photo of you that said next on it yeah
what i mean like that's basically what
all the press releases come down to like
it's ridiculous they just do not want
you to use their stuff at all
they're they're they're an interesting
bunch yeah
so let's see so uh
want to get uh note back in here so
um for this season obviously void 3.0
has been big
have you been what class have you been
playing the most so far with uh this
season
uh i started out doing warlock for the
first time okay i usually do hunter but
i think
i
forgot what the reason was behind it but
i feel like i think with the void
changes i wanted to try out warlock as
well
um
i'm still trying to learn about the void
changes because i haven't been on all my
characters and like messed around with
the fragments and stuff
but honestly
i think the titan one is my favorite so
far
with like the over shields
but i do like the warlocks little like
bubble that you can like it's like a
melee child of the old gods yeah
yeah i actually really enjoy throwing
that i don't know
the projectile melee yeah that you you
can also
no the head no it's not it's not the
same
you could chain off devourer you could
chain off well builds with it it's
really it's really good too
sorry i'm enjoying it nice um
i saw you did your three-man of the
disciple did you run void in that as
well or did you you guys have to mix
that up on that one
we did three-man rule
um okay do you want to do like the
three-man like whole raid because that
was actually really fun like my first
time doing a three-man anything
um every time i run bow i always do void
especially for damage because the wall
roll you need damage yes you know like
output
so as a warlock um
you don't well is pretty much useless
yeah it's useless in there i agree he
moves all the time even though you can
probably like stand still but he'll
he'll probably kick you out completely
he seems to target wells and bubbles he
goes
surprisingly i'm not mad at that though
like i feel like the whole raid is anti
because if even if you look at the
caretaker account on the moving from
plates like you're not putting a well
and just staying stationary
and i don't mind it i actually actually
thought it was a cool design thing to
switch it up and make other things
useful i'm sorry dope
it's actually pretty nice too because
you always see well in bubble yup you
don't see any other super especially in
like jams and stuff i don't know if void
will be good in jams because it hasn't
been out yet but i feel like it would
especially with devourer changes as well
um we also have the what's it called the
void volatile yeah
i'm hoping that we're going to see more
of especially noble bomb and i don't
know about nova warp though i don't
really even mess around with that
subclass i'm with your girlfriend
i was going to no i was like i feel like
nova bomb definitely can have its place
now in pve it feels like good damage
chunk paired with the void you've got
your devour for healing you've got your
wells your rifts and now especially with
your exotic boots your wells that do
damage heal you now like you guys have
some crazy stuff going on yeah but again
nova warp does seem like
now i gotta run over into the mix
that seems a bit risky as opposed to let
me chunk my giant space bomb over there
and blow that that seems safer so i was
like noble warp still seems one of those
that's
not as great for high level stuff
probably can blow plenty of stuff up at
mid-level content but
it's underwhelming super
i think but i i like the changes i
really do
i like the uh the hunter as well um i
think it was with mobius quiver um
especially with the i think it's the
boots i forgot what the boots are called
the exotic orpheus
orpheus
morpheus rig that gives you three
charges that's actually really good for
dps as well they buff that big time yes
[Music]
i'm glad they did that was that's my
favorite super is the top tree tether
like
okay okay okay you said you was enjoying
titan now so let's talk talk some titan
though i got two titans they they need
to feel the love they've been feeling
neglected
excuse me
so come on
what's the titan build you like it tell
us about that
the titan bill i don't remember the
fragments i have but i do have the one
where it grants you
i think overshield
for your allies
yeah i'm not exactly sure i'm still like
bastian i think is that one the
overshield with the barricade and stuff
like that yeah i remember that name yep
it's bastion i think the other one i did
read up on one of the fragments
um
i don't remember
i think it gives you heals over time
with volatile
i think it has something to do with void
volatile because i run void a lot
especially with my um
iu shares uh the smg
yes i run that
so i have like the whole build with void
that's like my favorite energy type oh
yeah
then they were like void 3.0 first and
you're like yes
oh yeah i'm so excited because like as a
tight as a hunter especially with tether
all the time oh yeah i loved it i was
like i can't wait for this i i was
waiting for orpheus rig to come back
because i don't think um
i don't know if it was as good back then
though because i i use wormhusk the most
okay you have to crutch it you know
health-wise
that's a that's a pvp
honestly if you're if you're a hunter
just using wormhusk then you should just
be playing as a titan if you want the
survivability just be a titan like
honestly i'm not too worried about
survivability because i can i'm actually
really good at surviving but i don't i
like it
yeah i swear i can use orpheus rigs i
can show you
[Laughter]
i'm happy to 1v1 you bro but all i'm
saying is i've heard wormhusk and i've
heard i really like overshields from the
void 3.0 for titans i just keep hearing
things that are like this lady likes to
survive she likes to take a little bit
extra damage
no no actually before the titan changes
especially over shields i ran thunder
crash
don't usually try to go ahead
[Music]
yeah so that's what i run i actually
have different builds for each other
yeah i love them i love titanfall what
is it for fog i was like where did you
go
go get them titans go get a boy yeah
i'll be happy when i see titans when i
ate the on the couch
it's really good for rook too
yeah
i think two of us did thunder crash with
curious and it was done it was like that
was then it hits
yeah that's one thing i noticed for me
um because i've been running divinity a
lot before
yeah i've been divinity guy for rulk and
when i'm on my titan
my super gets zero use because the
bubble gets like kicked in the head and
then i'm obviously not gonna use my
shields and then we'll go play my alt
and i'll go jump on my warlock and then
i'm like all right dps up i'll literally
chunk my nova bomb out and then start
div and i'm like cool i at least get to
do some damage now damage
yeah when i sit there is my titan and
that'd be the nice thing same as the
hunter now so the titan dps is
void dps is really weak but then we get
to turn around and do thunder crash
which is nice but yeah i've been running
divinity so i haven't been enjoying the
thunder crash as much since oh
but yeah but thunder but yeah we did try
that for i don't know if it was day one
we were doing that but it was
yeah it is very nice because when he
moves it's a big that big instant junk
damage and if you hit him kind of just
like fade away you'll usually dodge the
lasers but yeah thunder crash has been
nice to use when you can but if i'm
stuck on divinity not so much
so much not so much i understand the
warlocks though but yeah void has been
honestly very fun i'm honestly curious
we got a little
piece of information confirmed
tassie didn't seem to uh believe it
since he made this video on he was like
arc 3.0 and solar 3.0 are coming in the
consecutive season so season 17 is one
of them season 18 is one of them and we
knew this so well they're like yeah
you're gonna get one a season and i was
like and that was i think one of the
questions why we were asking about like
pvp maps was there season 19 then we
realized there's a season 19
um i'm guessing season 19 is be like all
right let's see if we can balance this
entire bundle of chaos is what my guess
is season 19 is going to be um
but i will be curious kind of when arc
3.0 and risk runner and solar 3.0 and
tq's divination and all these other
things start playing in because they
seem to have embraced wells a lot
um
because they've kind of made orbs of
light harder to get and harder to pick
up and now wells make them on kills and
there's a
uh what is it one of the fragments i
think no it's just one of the void wells
like when you use your class ability
your next kill green c void wells then
you can just start proc and that's just
using your class ability everybody has
that and you can get that all the time
so it's the wells they seem to be
leaning into more
yeah i'm like but then when i go to
another class i'm like man i feel like
hamstrung so i was like i want those new
ones but it is nice to know i just
wonder which one do you guys want more
do you want arc or solar next
any of you by the way nope you get to go
first that's a good question so i was
actually thinking about this the other
day i think i was talking to my chat um
talking about the other changes to like
arc and solar
and
i was saying
that hunter
has basically no arc
besides arcstrider
right
so the other supers or the other
characters have what three
three separate ones
i think right two or like two
two yeah usually two variations what do
you think of hunter rorlock's got tingle
tick tickle fingers and kamehameha wave
and uh titan's got
two types of the same power kind of
single smash and roaming smash and then
yeah hunters get a stack has one
yeah so i'm thinking i'm hoping that
they implement something new for hunter
arc
that would at least be like kind of
kind of a little bit more of
they can't really do much about like not
even like a chaos reach or something
like that but i i hope they do something
that actually like
we would be able to use like i would
look like what if you're
so the one thing i saw kevin diana say
is
arc might also include things like
mobility the way the yep psyonox spear
that we've got in psyops is uh kind of
and you can get that double blink i
would actually think it'd be really cool
since you have a staff to
i don't know if you could boomerang the
spear or if you could throw your staff
and somehow like pull it back if they
could actually get like like the god of
war axe animation like throw it and
recall it type thing that would be
probably op but actually would be really
really cool because you guys already
have the big weapon that almost is like
our artifact this season that would be
really cool i want solar personally next
because i want to mess around with all
my solar titan hammer stuff that's the
one i want like titan smash is you know
it is what it is at this point but i
just want to mix and match sun spots
with explosive tracking hammers or i
just want to mess with that subclass so
bad because solar titan is usually my
go-to if i can get a choice i just don't
right now it just feels underpowered
uh nerf dawn blade oil back mhm
feeling well obviously feeling well has
got to come back i mean clearly but
david
no that's not coming back no that'll
break the game
like dog blade is very very
underwhelming in my opinion with dps
especially pve if pvp is okay
i got a build for you i got a bill so
you don't sleep i got one bill for you
yeah you use the use the buggy eye
helmet the um
yes
use don chorus
door grenade because it has a burning
effect right
and
bottom tree dawn
the organic first to initiate the burn
tick on a boss then bottom tree dawn and
you can out dps uh chaos reach
they got a buff they got a buff recently
like a very quiet buff recently on the
super but only with that exotic yeah
that exotic but trust me
prior to that i'm 100 kind of like
thundercats though with curious like
thundercrash on its own isn't quite
worth like just using the one-off but
with curious it's a big enough chunk
yeah it is the same so that sounds that
sounds right they are leaning to if you
want dps with your super
here's an exotic you can go there yeah
yeah
i definitely i'm i'm glad they're
reworking pretty much subclasses there
are a lot of a lot of it's over like
underwhelming but i'll be happy with
either arc or solar next next season
yeah for me i i think um
i think for the wall i probably i'm okay
with solar right now
but i think the arc i think or i've kind
of like cooled off on it like i don't
really
it was you know it was a moment i was
geomagging you know what i'm saying get
my way up getting that on but between
like i don't feel i mean they made some
changes between top
tree arc and bottom tree arc to try to
differentiate them to give them um some
differences but they it does need a
rework it really does so i think i'm
looking for and plus i want to synergize
my favorite new posts in the game
i want to synergize with that insidious
false
three out of five three out of five for
my craftables i'm five out of five oh
dammit i'm jealous oh
you got five already uh you got alloys
too i pulled it out of the chest twice
the dual chest and then i bought it each
week as my you know the one that you can
buy from the guy i've been on
i'm jealous dragonfly rampage go extra
bro i will live with that gun until i
get that wrong yeah
should i do enhanced dragonfly or
enhance oh
is it called
adept
it's enhanced traits yeah they're
enhanced no not that not the traits the
mod the mind the mod that you can put in
rampage will last longer dragonfly
better explosions explodes i would
probably drink the explosion so yeah
probably yeah
it's a real sophie's choice yeah
i don't think it's that dramatic i'll be
honest it's that dramatic
when you're about to 1v1 nope it's
pretty important yeah oh yeah you
definitely need that for nope she's
about to smoke
you might do targeting adjuster on that
one then completely different build
totally different
are you one being one of me with a pulse
rifle oh judgement
i'm actually one of you wanting you with
two pulse rifles
i'm not bringing my a-game come on i
don't want to i don't want him because
she's about to smoke i like her i i'm
actually a sniper
go pitch his head off tell your words
what happened to him
i think you meant to say you were a
smack now you're retired no i promise
you the flinch
when there's a pulse rifle or like a
scout rifle is horrendous so you'll
probably win
pulse
when i get when i get killed by a guy
that that is using a sniper rifle while
i'm shooting them i'm like how did you
do that because i have no ability to aim
exactly yeah
let's see i'm going
to your point um trap i probably would
go
um yeah with the enhanced dragonfly and
probably do
probably the rampage specs so you get a
little extra seconds for the rampage you
know do that join but yeah insidious is
so good wait what's the role for it
it's one of the few posters that can run
roll with dragonfly rampage yeah you can
get both on it it's arc and it's it's
just a really good oh so
chunky chunky nice it's just
oh i was oh i have a dragonfly but i
have adaptive munitions with it though
ah
dragonfly makes the roll and that didn't
survive for now but once you get that oh
and oh it's gonna be so the other one
and there's like three that i want
that's one of them dragonfly rampage
just blow stuff up do more damage blow
stuff up do more damage that'll be fun
um
demolitionist and adrenaline junkie
oh
that's a good one pair them together so
you start stacking the damage then if
you need to reload chunk the grenade
grenade then you get the damage it's
just it's a very very good synergy it's
got stats for all in one for all
so if you can just hit three different
targets then you get that 35 increase
for like 10 seconds and then the stats
on stats um stats for all is handling
stability reload and
range and 35 damage if you just tap
three targets and then just start
killing them
yeah like it it's and it has adapted
munitions too and like rapid hit
adaptive munitions i mean you can do
it's
you could have four different versions
of that thing and i think that's what
annoys me a little more about the
crafting
is the fact that there are four
different ones i want to experiment with
yes but then i need to go make four of
them because i can't just like forever
unlock a perk
so we'll see when we get there anyway
we did get a patch on tuesday since you
know we're trying to talk about this
game destiny that we play sometimes i
swear
no it's elgin right now yeah this is
going to be yeah if three of us have
anything this saturday
we will have to get your take on it just
try not to hate it before you start yes
i'm i'm i'm absorbing the the travis zen
there you go he said calm down he said
just one thing you try to find one thing
there you go yep
destiny i would not have made it as far
as i am in destiny's coverage if i
didn't follow that rule i'm serious
because there's been times where being a
destiny stand has been tough but if you
just like yeah
you if you look for the light you can
find that one thing that keeps you going
but yeah the patch no no you're good uh
the patch did fix the issue with gambit
and pve values so there's no more
one-shotting of ariel on his foul so
that's fixed thank goodness
uh they fixed a couple of issues in val
a couple issues in the
campaign uh we did get the changes to
the economy for crafting so
um you've got your new currency limits i
already hit the neutral limit so i'm
just pissed off all over again i want to
go clean out the red weapon oh it's like
all right i saved up the right
explanations all right clear clear clear
you've hit the neutral element limit
damn it i'm like i'm already there so i
have
282 ruinous element i have 10 000 and
i'm just going
how many alloys you got
oh like six or seven i've been doing
some of the weekly campaigns the
campaign replay stuff yeah yeah like
this week you can do 100k
on match on hero
oh
yeah gilly go do yeah just the way the
game is
uh what is it the last chance mission
it's the apothecary one there's enough
enemies in there yeah there's enough
enemies in there with three people match
made 100 like i ended up with like 108k
oh yeah
yeah
so just make sure you're killing
everything easy just try and find like
if anything just try and focus the
champions down if everything dies you'll
get the kills that's the nice that one's
not too bad um so we did get the weapon
crafting economy changes i still think
neutral should be higher but i'm not
going to try to harp on that too much we
did last week
uh let's see for gameplay they've got a
couple of weapons um
not too much really changed they did
actually the laurely splendor helm
this exotic titan helmet has already had
like three different changes to it so
now they said it would consume the class
ability energy of like trying to make
the sunspot when you die
now it won't do that and take your class
ability energy away when you die so it's
a little bit better cool guys actually
been raving about it on twitter so i'm
sure he will be talking about that
yeah he had a rap before oh he well no
he's just he's finally like reviewing
different exotics and i think he's
getting this one like uh guys this one's
actually pretty good so don't sleep on
it oh yeah i loved it uh but the big one
that's kind of one i would ask you guys
about void 3.0 we already got some
changes for it
so they said sentinels titan bastion
barricade now takes 20
increased damage from player sources
so our barricades have been knocked down
a bit and that also it stacks with stuff
like hockey breach and anti-barrier so
those shields are going to get taken out
fairly quickly if people are spec right
for them
targets with void and invisibility
active now ping the radar every 0.6
seconds
every 3 second or 4.6 seconds i'm sorry
every 3 seconds until invisibility ends
normal radar villages ability rules
apply double jumping sprinting stuff
like that
basically
from what i can tell you're going to see
him a little bit because you can shoot
somebody and they won't even come out of
invisibility right now but they will now
ping the target a little bit they also
said fix an issue with child the old
gods could damage some targets through
immunity shields
so warlocks once again cheating
[Laughter]
no but i kind of wanted to see um since
we got the titans and then um for our
hunter maine what are your thoughts on
the invisibility changes that now
you're basically going to be pinging the
radar every three seconds for just a bit
do you think that's a fair change for
invisibility do you lean heavy into it
when you play are you sad are you happy
are you okay with it
me yeah
i'm actually okay with it
um even though i kind of have it in this
build um
i don't usually do it in pvp anymore but
i know a lot of people are were very
upset with invis hunters in pvp
and i hope this actually like mellows
them out a little bit because i honestly
don't like hearing about it anymore
i actually like the idea of them
pinging it a little bit
um i
i
actually don't know um i i want to see
how it looks and how like it feels
when it happens
but i actually i actually do hope
it eases people's minds with it
but i know it can be annoying like not
seeing a hunter and like getting shot at
the back or something like that you know
it it can get annoying like i agree with
it
and hopefully this uh this works out
but
yeah
what about you guys have you been facing
any of those invisible hunters have they
been annoyance to you have you all of a
sudden been like i don't see anybody
dead snipes to a guy who's just sitting
there in the open just looking at you
anybody had those fun experiences yet
mike i've got two people smiling over
here for you audio listeners so i'm
waiting for one of them to talk
i'll let you out yeah for sure i i i
actually don't know if invisibility is
the biggest broken thing in in uh the
void 3.0 meta but it is certainly one of
the annoying things but i'm kind of like
nope like i'm tired of people
complaining about it like we all know
that the pvp sandbox is not balanced
right now void 3.0 saw sure to that
ark and solar are next to useless
because the other subclasses are clearly
better right now even stasis feels a
little weak by comparison in some
subclasses certainly for titans
um but i i think that they they probably
just need to
calm down let bungie fix it they do this
all the time i'm just staying out of the
pvp honestly the pvp sandbox for now
like i'll just i'll come back to it when
they fix some things but i've sort of
learned when they do big sandbox changes
whether it's adding stasis or doing void
3.0 that they tend to not care at all
about how that's going to affect pvp and
it takes them a couple months to get it
back into alignment so
i'm i'm prepared to wait and play elden
ring while i while i do so so um yeah
that's kind of my strategy is wait it
out but i the little pvp i have to play
it has been a little bit like all right
this isn't super balanced even titans
aren't balanced like getting an
overshield whenever you want is kind of
especially like
you put down the barricade you get the
overshield still from going away from it
like a rift you know that's like
i put down the barricade i walk in front
of it and then i kill the person because
i've got an overshield and then they're
like why did you do that and i'm like
because bungie said i could yeah it's
like a riff that you can walk with you
know it's like a it's like a walking
dead
that far away from it you have to be
standing basically right next to it
still let's get ease feedback from black
because you know from last week i was
hearing a bunch of crying and whining
let's talk about that is that fair is
that is that
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys have had
like healing rifts for like four years
so
now you're feeling some of some of the
other side of like somebody else with
the shield so like the healing risks
it's true have been and you put that i
don't think warlocks have any to any
room to complain about this because
their rifts have been like the spammiest
like i don't know how to play pvp so i'm
just gonna
listen
good good okay
bottom arch
for warlock
is actually really good especially with
this guy
i got my two little spiders
yeah you got your little you got turrets
that's the thing it's like you don't
even have to look at me and i'm still
getting hit by something else and nobody
else has something like that really
obnoxious
the um no time to explain post and have
the real aggressive one
like i got the two stitches
what do you think
what do you think about this overshield
yeah kiss our butt
yeah that is the most like disgustingly
casual build i've ever heard and i know
exactly how to counter it and would have
no problem killing you but like just
hearing somebody say that aloud is like
offensive
hey we got a gauntlet that we could turn
our grenade into the snitch
automatically
if you heard
with me in pvp because i do both
pretty much i do both sides i try to
think of the worst and the best case
scenarios like instead of going oh
whatever in this hunter blah blah i try
to think of like like what i can do to
counter that as well not a lot of people
can or do that
you know especially like overshield it's
really annoying because you have like
the extra health or whatever in this
hunter you can also they don't have
extra help they just have invisibility
whatever you shoot them you know but it
is annoying you know not being able to
see them from like a corner and then
then coming out and like shooting you
yeah they typically get the first shot
in that yeah yeah
yeah i try to think of both sides to the
uh the cases and aspect of the the pvp
sandbox you know but dmt is the worst
thing that's ever happened in the game
i haven't seen them or at least i must
be killing them because i have not seen
dna every so often i get killed by one
and it is it's fast
before the changes
that's like the only thing i will
complain about is how dmt is way too
like i think overpowered or was i should
say was because right now i don't see a
lot of it and i'm i'm really happy about
that but that's the only thing i would
complain about in pvp
yeah
right now
you
running around
that's terrorized or yes nor is one and
then the likely suspect is the other
void one
deliverance i've been seeing
from the raid yeah deliverance will do
it too well because it's a stasis slide
so you can use different stuff in your
energy
pc now
i do yeah ah yeah so dmt is a lot
stronger stronger pc
thank you thank you i appreciate you uh
yeah it's like because yeah you can get
messed up by dmt and the console is like
what are you talking about it's like
we don't have a problem yeah that's fine
in my experience most of the bungie
people play on playstation so they
probably don't even know it's a problem
oh yeah i see but it is yeah it's like
the dmt i i'm in the same way it's like
it did have the amos's taken away fire's
a little slower from hip fire i think so
those changes seem to brought it in a
little bit every so often when i do i
don't see it much but when i do get
killed by it i'm just like damn that was
fast it is it is a quick gun if
somebody's still good with it it's still
got some potency to it but i don't think
right now at least it doesn't seem
overbearing per se but when it comes to
this
fusion seem to be the main issue now
because they're sold god roll main
ingredient number two
so now they have the first week it came
back too
yeah yep so firmly planted tap the
trigger and then firmly plant and some
people were saying is better than under
pressure tap the trigger
and then you've also got so well then
cool guys all about i've been writing
with cool guys so he's actually i love i
love getting like the insights he's like
i'm diving into this one this week
yeah
yeah i was a little smooth but tell me
what cool guy talking about
he's hilarious he reminds me of you
cog because he'll like he'll find some
way to make anything work
he's going to be like all right i'm
going to go step out of the box wander
over into aisle 7b
pick up this exotic he's the hippie of
builds that's why i love him yeah he's
gonna go be like i'm gonna make this
weird thing and then all of a sudden
he's like all right you should use this
in this way now granted whatever he came
out with what was the one recently oh
it's the hunter
staff exotic he's like it's just bad it
just sucks he actually he normally will
find something good about most things he
did not like the increased damage
reflection one and i even wondered the
same thing when we heard about that i'm
like you can only reflect well where are
you going to use this and still it's not
very good but um likely suspect the
craftable fusion from throne world
it's void
so you've got firmly planted which
basically makes it insanely stable tight
groupings and then
you're gonna add it to successful
warm-up
[Music]
so you've got firmly planted very easy
like very tight groupings with your
bolts to get that first kill and then
you got eight ten seconds on warm up to
get that second one and it's gonna fire
faster than anything else
so if you can pair that together and
start stacking them up some ammo and if
you know the really good pvpers are like
sliding into corners and stuff and no
it's he yeah that one is
is definitely one to toy around with so
if you want a pvp fusion rifle the
likely suspect firmly planted and
what did i just say oh successful
warm-up successful you can definitely
put some work in with that one for sure
interesting okay check that out yeah
right now i wait i'm almost got a d semi
decent funnel web of close but right i
mean this was decent i got steady hands
and adrenaline junkie
and um i got a subsistence addre i got a
subsistence adrenaline or frenzy are you
guys just going to talk about your roles
all night or
i mean
when you got it when you got it it's
just exchanging
yeah it's like all right this is the
show now
what what's wrong with that no i'm just
kidding
like is this good
it's brilliant content guys brilliant
content
just go through your whole vault
let me pull up let me pull up
i'm good to go over here yep
for sure oh i want to know how do you
guys pronounce the sniper roll sniper
rifle f-u-g-u-e-55
nope go first how do you pronounce that
sniper rifle
cog how do you pronounce it
i like it
it's french apparently
i call it the forget about it
i like that
yeah i was on the fugue train i was just
we were joking about that too and i was
just kind of curious i saw that one too
um
but those are the main real one though
what's the real name for it though i've
never actually looked up the real
pronunciation
probably
the answer is probably f-u-g-e like like
it's probably just like a robot
like you're redeeming a code
actually maybe
f-u-g-u-e no
f-u-g five-five all right
uh
hold on one second are we stream
yeah oh no it's it's just hourglasses
just lagging let me refresh it see if it
comes hold on no no no i'm seeing it too
it's back it's back i did refresh
are you sure i'm not oh no now it came
it was back then it went away again
yes i'm saying it
it's loading
what happened to the stream i never they
got so bored by our
wow
wow
thanks
sorry everybody we had a little bit of
technical difficulties in the middle of
the podcast obs crashed so there is a
bit of a jump here when things kind of
got back up and going but we should be
good to go right after this thanks
everybody for listening now back to the
show
big things that i want to talk to you
guys about though uh while we still got
it um on audio
yeah just on audio
is
we had this will be fun edit later on
game to give they recapped they had over
two million uh total donated for the
game to give they had 38 500 donors 575
fundraisers who supported across 103
countries so honestly like really crazy
numbers that they hit that's the highest
they've ever done so i definitely wanted
to shout that one out i know we talked
about a lot of it before because you
know i had my piece and stuff but just
very cool numbers uh they did also
mention they kind of released their
first issue of bans with regards to
account recups
whether it's you know recuvs for
leveling up services that people use in
a poor way where somebody's cheating or
trials
via recurves now we'll get you banned so
one of those things definitely to watch
out for
which is kind of a big thing but the
main topic we got a patch coming on
tuesday which you know means there's no
zur holding hostage and stuff like that
we've got a couple other known issues
they went into all the bad actor stuff
that we talked about in the twab
um and then how to handle if you want to
upload licensing but basically they just
said it was someone else doing it that
shouldn't have been never was authorized
so they did clarify a decent amount that
main thing that i wanted to actually
discuss with you guys raid challenges
psyops battlegrounds on legend
difficulty and just the increased
difficulty that launched this week i
just wanted to get you guys thoughts on
if you know the raid challenges or the
raid triumphs for like the encounters
and then also your thoughts on legend
psyops battlegrounds
if um
if you like him if you don't i mean i
have my thoughts i'm trying not to leave
the audience leave the witness too much
here
um but first i wanna start the raid do
you guys know what the challenges were
or do you need a recap or have you even
done it yet
i did this week's which was
that we had to all kill our abomination
at the same time
yep yep
or you can leave them but that's more uh
annoying
than easy
i think you can do either or but killing
them like at the same time
you just leave them alive
i would not do that it gets too chaotic
but
a lot i thought it was pretty
straightforward forward just leave them
to juggle but it was cool
a lot of people thought it was too easy
but it kind of is okay let me ask you if
you want to juggle that on master
difficulty
i'll do it for sure
you want to keep those guys up on master
yeah
people want hard content that's hard
i'm telling you i'm just kidding i
probably wouldn't honestly
so the other piece is take the challenge
the triumph that you can get on the same
encounter or you can't attack you can't
kill the orange bars
until they start attacking the obelisk
the two guys with the shields yeah i saw
that so that's the challenge i hate that
terrible idea terrible challenge
it's like i don't like any challenge
that's like play the game poorly yeah
put yourself in a losing predicament how
do you not like that one but you're okay
keeping a champion up this is my
disconnect here i'm like you just said
what i was hoping you to say on the
first one
but you didn't say it
the first one is not keep the champion
up the first one is everybody kill the
champion at the same time
yeah but you should do either order but
you know i don't keep it up we we were
just we were on it when it would spawn
we'd be like all right everybody kill
your champion no but you as long as you
kill it within five seconds it's done
yeah you gotta kill them all together
but whoever gets it to spawn first still
has to play like the game of dodgeball
for a little while until those things
come up because it's gonna stay if
you're first that thing will stay up for
a decent while
that's true that long you're still gonna
stun them though that's the thing with
the other guys you can't stun them you
have to wait for them to run down
fight the obelisk you know do a 2v1
and then you know kill them well
you can easily
stun them like what five six times more
sure i didn't think about you would have
stoppables yeah i guess my problem is
that one of them is
strategic it's like
an extra thing to juggle that is
actually a challenge and the other one
is literally just
it's pointless like what
i kind of agree with that like you just
let them shoot once again you're good
yeah it's like you play the game poorly
for a little bit and then all of a
sudden you do the thing you're supposed
to do and then that's the challenge like
it's not even really
not even really a challenge it's just a
weird video
what's the
the raid reward for doing the
abomination like the
champion challenge that's another chest
that's the most extra chest that's a
bonus chest accessory unstoppable comes
out because i haven't done a raid this
week so unstoppable comes out
you just have it all four keep them
alive and then we say all right ready
guys one two three kill yourself
unstoppable yeah okay yeah okay
the first guy who gets to despawn got to
play around
that's my issue because i was thinking
on like
it's long enough that on master
difficulty that is going to be rough is
all i'm saying because it's already
going to be overleveled unless you're
just like living in it and i know some
people get up to like season past 2 20
you know 250 or 300 whatever if you get
high enough up there i'm sure it won't
be as bad but that guy is going to hit
really hard if you have to keep him up
for a while you got you've just got to
you got to be quick on on the call out
when you see him stun him and then
handle your business but it's not it's
it's just annoying it's an annoyance i
guess
both pieces of this encounter for me bug
me because it's
don't kill enemies yet
yeah keep these enemies up and it's just
like so you want me to not
shoot things in the game where i shoot
things and shoot them to do a challenge
and it's like
so try and dodge and especially in like
high level content you want the master
chest twice right
like that's that that's i don't like the
design of that challenge i've always
liked challenges where it's a different
way to do the mechanic versus put you in
a
compromising situation that's unnatural
due to gameplay you would never keep
anything up for any reason you would
never allow someone to put you in a
losing state
you know it's just it's just bad game
design all that because yeah the chat
the champions you have
you're going to be able to stun them
sure but you have to wait until they get
out of stun to re-stun them yeah now
it's like the other option like
unstoppables on that one theoretically
what you would do is line up side them
stun them in line of sight
they'll probably wander i don't know how
aggressive they're going to be i know in
like lost sectors or nightfalls if you
stun them and get out of line of sight
they just wander around aimlessly while
you peek at them again so that's
probably what you're gonna have to do
but again the way the enemies spawn or
if you have to go after it just i didn't
like the design of the challenge and i
maybe and apparently it was just me more
not liking it but also the shield guys
we were trying to do that first because
we thought that was the challenge until
somebody saw like a post on reddit or
something be like it's actually the
champions but i was like we're just not
killing guys when we should be killing
guys it just seemed
not like a very creative challenge on
this one so agreed
but i guess my my the bigger one and i
still haven't even done it yet because i
don't see a point to it outside of the
war table insight is the legend psiops
battlegrounds
so they're 1550
they are not match made which
they're at the powerful cap not the
pinnacle cap not master legend 1550 not
match made
no additional rewards
and this is how you also progress this
seasonal challenge is a non-match made
activity to get your insight this week
it is in legend
that is how you get your insight this
week
yep
and i think that is i mean that's that's
the reason that they didn't put any
rewards behind it is because you have to
do it if you want to get
your uh table done i think that they
thought that would be motivation enough
to do it i logged on and was doing like
my weeklies and i saw that and i was
like i'll skip this week i'll see if i
need it by the end of the activity
because i was like i already kind of
don't like psyops battlegrounds and the
the thought of having to
talk to cog on comms or something was
just like oh god i'll just play
something else like i don't want to do
that
so yeah
i i might try it because 1550 isn't that
intimidating
it's not like it's grand master knife
yeah or whatever but it is kind of
irritating and no match mate is stupid
but you know boot to orbit all that too
i actually did it yesterday with duo i
mean it's a little chaotic but
i've always had like trouble staying
alive in that one for some reason like
even like normally with the champions
that spawn and it's
like
and her like
balls coming at you it just hurts way
too much honestly um but duo it was not
okay i mean it was okay sorry i
completely did that yeah
i've called the black the taken knights
the big black ball of death i mean
they've i've had a lot of weird things
there's a lot of or there are a lot of
spherical things that you definitely
call it
[Laughter]
too much in the game yeah there's a lot
of balls in this game so
i mean the traveler's one big white ball
so it's fine yes yes the thing though is
the non-matchmaking
it is annoying especially if you're a
solo player yes especially because you
said it's a mission technically
and you're a solo player how are you
gonna progress besides doing a solo yep
it's gonna be way too hectic and i feel
bad for people like having to do that
you know but on duo it's it's doable it
was not too bad yeah two or three
because it doesn't scale the way
like the legendary campaign those guys
got scaled and got beefier and they said
it was gonna scale none of the other
content scales so with three people if
you match make it's not gonna be bad
and it's you know you might die or
whatever but the fact that there's not
matchmaking and nightfalls need legend
difficulty as it's just the powerful cap
should be match made now maybe you
should be
15 45 to matchmake like you need to be
close i don't want to see somebody
matching in there like 1480. like i know
it's match made but there probably needs
a power cap but if you're at 1550 or
something you should be able to match
make that activity and then the fact
that there's i was honestly hoping
because we talked about this last week
or a legend i was like maybe you get one
red bar from doing on led or run one red
outline from legend or
anything and it was just yeah
like you can't just have people that's
my that's my new thing i'm like what's
the reward oh
yeah
we go back to like is the juice worth
the squeeze so you got so this is a
weird week for me and this is i guess
why i'm bringing all this together is
because
for me it was raid challenges that make
you play in a way where you have to
play dodgeball not kill these things too
fast or wait till they start killing the
thing that you don't want them to touch
so you got to be a little tighter on the
timing just because we want you to be
or the abominations if you want to keep
those alive and i'm picturing masker
master the first person who gets that
there's going to be a lot of deaths
trying to do that on master like the
first person eventually just doesn't
play that one right and then i see
legend and i'm like talking to my chat
and stuff and they're like yeah legend
and then they're asking if you wanted to
do it but it was like oh i can go jump
in later no big deal after we do the
raids and then i see it's not match made
and there's no reason besides the
insight and i'm going
this week hit wrong and especially as
elden ring is just calling me to go play
something that is just i don't want to
stop
when these things hit the way this does
i'm like cool the raids are done but man
i don't care about anything else right
now and then legend just adds nothing
it was just a weird weird week for me so
i didn't know if anybody else felt that
way or if i'm just like you know whining
over here
no you're speaking real stuff i i i
completely agree with you i think that
that sucks the enjoyment out of doing a
newer a quote unquote new activity
last question on the subject um is the
regular um psyops given the thing the
energy thing oh no
i mean regular side of the inside no
yeah okay no you have to it's only
weekly
yeah you have to complete the challenge
every week in order to get the uh to get
this right and the challenge this week
is do it on got it got it
cool
you know
[Laughter]
yeah it's just like that's one of those
when
you can't give me a harder difficulty
and give me no reason to do it
and even if it is like you can
you know maybe they do a thing where
it's a checkbox or something if you're
gonna do legend you can get at least one
red outline and then it's like a deep
sight would be rare
if you knew that was like hey there was
a chance to do that type of stuff and
you're going after crafting yeah then
you'd be like all right uh black wings
new red let's go let's run this thing
like four or five times get some chances
at some deep sites and then maybe it's
like when you do it you also get double
risen number energy like just give me
something in there
to make it worthwhile that's that was my
biggest thing and i know that's kind of
just a little rant but that was
between the challenge and the legend
syabs i was just like this hit so wrong
in multiple ways for me it's like i did
the raids those were fun and then i saw
those and i was like
yeah no not food but i i agree just not
not handled right and nope am i a big
whiner or were you at on this
um
no you're definitely not a big one like
i i 100 agree
i agree i agree honestly because i think
only masters should have non-man like
non-match made like it's a heart of
content what it's like 1580 or something
like that like above 1550
you're like you're dealing with
champions and all that and i think um as
like lower content
like if there was a whole i don't know
if you remember the whole controversy of
like dares and the champions
like
in normal mode
it's kind of like that like people don't
want to see champions when you first get
in the game you know because people
don't know what mods are don't know what
champions are so it's kind of like that
but
like with legend obviously you're not
gonna be new
technically yeah
but
i definitely agree that
everything up until masters should be
match made yeah 100 percent
so they should i don't know if they ever
will though i i i really don't i guess i
don't know what's stopping them because
the way they've got the leveling
structure done now especially if seasons
just go up like 10
and they don't need to over make
anything overly much more difficult
then it's just like it seems like
that would be one of those things maybe
make the level requirement when you hit
1550 then you could match make otherwise
you gotta have a group just so people
are
you know nobody's trying to jump in
please carry me at 1500 and just hope
for the best like i can see a little
let him in let him in let the 1510s in
you know why
because you added matchmaking to trials
okay okay
just do it all i mean
it doesn't scale on account of them so
actually i'm okay with that if they're a
body that can shoot something
that is not actually horrible because it
doesn't scale the way the campaign made
the enemies tougher that i guess i get
okay but it's like
yeah if you're 115 you know it's like
i'm 15 72 or whatever it's like whatever
with the artifact
and then two people jump in and they're
like
oh what's this difficulty
that would suck so i was like i don't
know there's there's probably a balance
of like
level dif level for matchmaking like you
got to be close like give me a window
for matchm
you'll benefit because hey look when you
die at least some of the enemies will
shoot at your ghost for no reason oh but
they're they're helping they're helping
you know they're destruction
yeah they're a distraction basically
i've had some trials uh teammates match
made that were about that useful so you
guys can deal with it that i get that i
get yeah but yeah it was funny because
you guys actually talked about champions
and stuff too i saw tassie and datto
both put out their videos on
kind of tired of champions
yeah champions suck they've always
sucked i talked about champions in my
shadow keeper view as sucking and now i
feel these years later i'm like damn i
was right they still suck yeah you know
i try to be over minded towards them but
it just
what it is i just hate
the artifact locking me into that field
i don't want to play and i just want to
have fun like there's times i'm like all
right i really want to use this you know
i mean insidious yesterday has pulse the
pulse has unstoppable but there's times
it's like all right it's anti-barry in
here so i have to take
blah blah blah or scout i'm saying i
have to take and i'm just like i just
want to play with these cool builds that
i made that i like you know it's just
that's restricted the legend campaign
showed us
how they can manage it with contests
with new enemies like hive guardians and
stuff like that i wanted to get your
thoughts on this note because i mean you
know you did three man uh rock you've
done gm's you've you've done a good
chunk of things i mean 3000 hours later
where are you at with the state of like
i don't wanna yeah where are you out
with champions because i don't wanna say
too much
um i honestly don't mind them i don't
really have a big problem with them um
but i think they do need to rework the
type of weapons to use
for for them yeah i think they should do
like two each like right now they have
smg auto rifle i love that because you
have two options
i think they should do that or do like
three like or four maybe yeah i'm
probably not four but like two or three
and i think they should do it for each
one like unstoppable overload you know
barrier like you do have really good
exotics though for anti-barrier
and you also have the new boots for
warlock they actually have overload
graphics overload intrinsically
don't be telling the secrets girl come
on
i think they should do more they're
gonna say i'm overpowered i got the easy
class again we gotta keep that down
when i first saw that i was like is this
a bug
i was like this is all my weapons have
overlapped
i love this class but that's that's
actually what like
you're saying cog though it limits you
though yeah but i think they should they
put like they should put in all exotics
no i agree
i agree you know um i don't mind them
but when people argue about you know
champions or horrible i want to see what
people would want more of them or what
okay i got an idea
easy
i got you right here travis north up
world class game designer okay so uh
let's go
put the light bearing hive
they're way better they're actually the
model for how they should do challenging
enemies they're threatening they have
abilities that make them unique to fight
against they can one shot you they're
actually threatening but they don't
control your play style at all they're
like
they're not irritating so like that's
the model is just make give us more
enemies like the light bearing hive that
are intimidating and and feel like
bosses without without making it super
annoying and it some of the champions
don't even work correctly the overload
champions are broken they've been broken
since they're annoying it's ridiculous
yeah so i just think
that that you know there's much better
ways to do what they're trying to
accomplish and i feel like they they
just really have stuck to their guns for
longer than they should have at this
point yeah hard to agree because the the
hive light the losing brew definitely
that even the the ghost killing mechanic
and it makes you move
it makes you move because let's be
honest destiny plays we tend to lay back
pick apart and i know you're going to
have to get in the mix and get him out
otherwise you're going to face this
terror all over your strategic tour you
clear all the ads clear out and you make
it safe
it makes you
play a certain way not what weapons you
use but it makes you get like physically
and encounters go push up not sit in the
back and that's why they make these
circular
boss rooms where you have nowhere to
hide because they don't want you to sit
in the back i'm like okay well make it
into me i gotta go chase like that's why
i like to roll so much is you can't just
sit you there is no sit in the back
there is
move dodge move down you know moving the
entire time durham and the during the
damage phase and stuff like that
so i mean no i agree with everything you
guys are saying the the hive are great
the new
like light bearing hive are awesome and
it is champions being just something
they've crushed them too hard and it's
the thing it's like i want to be able to
just like
i want to be able to put on my arms
barrier and overload just blanket and
just be like hey if it's a champion
activity and you don't want me to use
the reloads to be limited that way
let me put hey you can say you can stun
barriers with whatever you got
i could shoot him with a rocket and at
least it could break the barrier but i
just have barrier breaking ability on me
and i just intrinsically have that
because like overload's the worst right
now because over because auto rifles and
smgs you got to sit there and like
pepper them with shots i'm sitting there
doing master and you're like gotta get
enough shots on them one sniper those
scoring crossbow guys are lethal
those guys are they they think they got
their damage turned up a little bit
really bad yeah they're just
disproportionately bad it's like i know
crossbows hit hard but i think somebody
like added an extra zero to their dps
value because i had the void resistance
on
and i nearly lost my full health bar off
of one hit from them i'm going if i if
anybody sneezes on me else i was dead so
those are those are the scoring that
kill kate you know what else is bad with
this morning is the grenades
oh
yes horrible you step in that once your
pinky toe you're done
you're done yeah because i was doing
that the totems yeah all of them are not
oh and it turned out so many chieftains
down yeah so many cheated yeah the
scorner
i hate the teleporting taken but man
those totems and grenades when they have
that stuff cranked up
yeah it's that is an unfun experience
it's like
we got to the campaign and i hope they
and this is again this is them learning
with things that they progress on but
and we will probably get multiple
seasons of very similar to what we have
right now but i'm hoping and say
lightfall and it sucks that we probably
have to wait 18 months to get this or 17
now because i expect a delay for
lightfall i don't see lightfall coming
in february but
for sure absolutely um
i'm hoping what they see like how the
campaign is so loved
the way they handled contests the way
the champions are not in there at all
literally never and yet it was still a
challenge and everybody loved that i
hope they embraced that model going
forward and i don't know if they like
phase out champions leave them in like
the legacy content whatever they do but
the the limitations again when i went in
it's like i gotta go smg or auto rifle
or i go void grenades for overload
but if you miss that grenade or you
don't nuke that one champion
then i gotta wait for my grenade to get
back if i lean into that and then it's
like well i'll be sitting here for a
little while and it's it just yeah it
limits your playstyle because today i
was doing the lost sector and it was
overload for metamorphosis and going
through
two of those chieftains in the beginning
a whole bunch of grenades flying at you
and the sniper is trying to pick you off
in the same little area i was going yeah
i got through it but it took me quite a
few tries to get through and
just reminded joy
no it just reminded me of the champions
i'm just like i am me along with
everybody is getting tired of them and i
think it's finally starting to come up
enough the only joy from champions i get
is what i hear
that sound you hit when you know you you
made it right you you activated the stun
yeah
when i hear that i'm like yes now i'm
going to kill you
you're going to get all this business
especially the overloads will get the
energy back instantly i'm like oh my god
also some of them don't even stun half
the time i've been noticing that
they definitely need to work on like the
timing as well
yeah well like for both if it worked
maybe i wouldn't be as mad but it's so
so frustrating last season when the
overloads wouldn't actually get killed
when you finish them yeah they would
actually come back yeah
they still heal when they're not
supposed to it's like they heal in
between the window when you can't stun
them after you've stunned them last time
and that is so easy so annoying and my
thing is you should not be allowed to
shoot me if i stunned you if i stun you
there should be no exchange exchange of
fire they still like this
well then like barriers or scouts which
if it's faster firing you can continue
to pepper the shots but with bows
if you don't have archer's tempo
basically proct
the draw time between a bow unless it's
just really fast you that health bar
gets enough time to like tick up for a
barrier especially on master because
it's always such a smaller window
it's i mean unstoppables honestly are
generally my worst worry or at least
worry because you stun them they chill
and then if you get out of the line of
sight stun them again yeah overload
barrier need technical steel yeah they
don't you know exactly yeah they don't
they're the only ones that don't heal so
you can play them but the other two
they're just broken to me enough times
that it's really frustrating so
they should heal maybe a little bit less
yeah or less fast in between yeah less
fast especially with overload they're
pretty they're quick if you're not on it
yeah
if they do everything if they teleport
it's over they're like teleport full
health like every time
well that was most of what i got i know
this is a bit of a wine here at the end
fest and sorry everybody about the
technical difficulties sorry nope you
got to experience obs crashing but as a
streamer it's like you've seen technical
difficulties so this will get yeah i'll
probably pull this down from my channel
it's out there edit and re-upload i'll
probably re-upload it tomorrow or
overnight or something after i get yours
up but
yeah um
i smell food
yeah i'm hungry i know my wife is
cooking something because every so often
once it like it takes a while to drift
into the office
something got cooked i'm like food so
apparently i'm hungry now too so it's
apparently time we wrap this up she
cooked your favorite
unseasoned dried beans
wow
wow
that's just that sounds terrible anyway
he's joking and giving me a hard time
i'm a picky eater so they give me a hard
time because i don't like
so i don't like i don't like condiments
we've covered that too i'm not gonna lie
i'm very bad at like eating yeah i'm
giving us your top three uh you're
uninvited to parties foods that you
sean
it's like it's more like condiments
technically not like food but no onion
no tomato okay i don't like
i don't like now do you not like tomato
sauce like do you like you don't like
pizza actually this is making more sense
makes sense i don't like the what's it
called like i call it pasta sauce
because you use pretty much
uh yeah like marinara
yeah i don't like that i usually do like
white sauce when it comes to pizza i'll
say i love a good marinara
you like marinara i eat pizza dude
you like tr i love when you're calling
me out on another podcast when i can't
defend myself because you're like he
doesn't like any sauce or anything at
all ever and then i'm over there like i
like this sauce really i like the sauce
really it's like amazing
blanket statement isn't actually true
but my blanket statement is fun to label
you with oh that feels so good i love
getting i love that
it doesn't add to the fun
it's true he doesn't like sauces i mean
i like some sauces just not a lot of
sauces
this is true i like that he doesn't he
doesn't drink any beverages because
they're too close to sauce
understandable
so there's water then gcx
we gotta take a gcx picture
see this is what i put up with every
week nope i'm trying to be a reasonable
guest i'm a reasonable host here
trying to keep these two in check and
then they say i eat plain bland food
and i'm over here like i like seasoned
food i enjoy spice i like a couple of
sauces but i don't like all things
and i'm sorry
cog just comes into the room with the
pizza and he just sees cog and i just
whooping on an e straw man just boom
just wailing on the scarecrow we built a
bee it's fun to create our own narrative
of him
yeah when i can't defend myself it's a
little more annoying
i can't only hope earth sauce catches on
if i contribute anything to the internet
it must be if anybody tags hashtags
somebody tag
earth sauce just tweet
earth thoughts if you hear this podcast
please
tag travis don't you tag me
oh god
my internet will do that for like like
1001 1002 i get this drop in internet
which happens every so often but that
you gave me water on a pc post dramatic
stress no still
[Laughter]
they're just going to get it later i'm
recording both of these yeah i'm
recording the audio in the video oh
you're doing it oh nice i don't know
like editing is going to be fun but yeah
i was like we'll get to that well anyway
nope thank you for joining us for a
weird episode
i appreciate you being here um there's
an absolute pleasure to actually get you
on because i know we've talked off and
on for a while now so happy to actually
have you on your podcast hopefully you
had a reasonable time with
the shenanigans of these other two
gentlemen here so
i actually had a great time thank you i
know you i think i've known you for a
while now like two years i think yeah
we've kind of like touched base on
twitter or something like that yeah it's
like so yeah
it was fun thank you thank you for
having me this is my second one and
actually really fun nice it's like out
of my comfort zone so it's actually
helping me out too you know trying to be
more socializing and like talk more so
thank you well if they're gonna do the
favor the background of the podcast is
your sump so you know that's why i
figured i noticed that actually it was
like
i like that little touch of detail in
there yeah yep see we go the extra mile
for our guests i got you a good intro
got you a good background we really
loved the intro that was amazing thank
you
we
try sometimes we can find little nuggets
to get you guys to chuckle so glad we
got you um yeah you guys do a great job
actually i really thank you i really
enjoyed it i gotta be in your podcast
more to be honest with you is it just
every thursday
or is it any other day it's generally
thursday nights like right now is when
we do it so yeah we'll usually be live
on youtube we'll usually tweet it out so
if you want to come hang out and chat
and hear more about earth sauce then um
i'll definitely come back for earth
sauce
if nothing else she's just gonna start
spinning that spam and that in chat and
i'm going to lose these two
and i'm going to be trying to talk about
something completely serious and they're
just going to break
next week next week just watch out for
it i'll be looking at jack you gotta go
uh well tell everybody where to find you
what you've been up to what um basically
anything you got going on uh the floor
is yours
uh my name is nope uh you can find me on
my stream on twitch uh twitch.tv sports
i've been trying to get just nope for
the longest time so right now it's just
i love it twitter is at uh nope it's you
h and then knop
the k is silent in my name um so it's
nope you know but with the kids
leslie knope yep no yeah like it parks
to recreation um that's probably why you
have a hard time getting that name by
the way you probably yeah
it is pretty popular so yeah you'll be
duking that one out for a while
someone on twitch does have it but they
don't have like anything on there so i'm
like trying to get that and especially
on twitter it's like 11 years old with
no there's like a couple tweets but that
was in like 2 000.
just get them just get them to post some
destiny footage and they'll get banned
and then you can that's actually cheerio
there you go
[Laughter]
full circle be like
way to bring it all the way around
travis nice job
no i don't think i would get the name
though if they they're active i don't
know if that would work on twitter would
that no yeah you need them to be like
hey you've been inactive for like seven
years okay deleted mm-hmm yeah i wish it
was like that like after 10 years just
delete the ad or something but yeah
they need that
i'll just end it with that those are
like my two main sources of where i
would be and like active like i'm not
really active on youtube not yet at
least
but yeah thank you for having me though
nice meeting you guys
absolutely travis what do you got uh we
got your review out so we got and then
you're covering a whole bunch of stuff
coming up i'm covering a bunch of a
bunch of games for gdc so indie games
you can see i'm gonna have some previews
up next week on thursday i think
um and then uh yeah my review of tiny
teens wonderland is live check it out
game comes out tomorrow it's it's a
great game you should you should play it
if you've got the time um you can watch
me uh debate a a
middle-aged uh lawyer every sunday at
seven a.m pacific on bitcast a show i do
with some of my buddies um
what's the what yeah you got so you got
ains you got hogue and then who's the
other guy and
the other guy is a live action role play
of um
i was going to say something really
offensive uh but let's just say that he
he looks like um
skeletor
meets
uh
meets like an an ogre is what i would i
would kind of classify him at maybe give
him
so yeah that's that's that also you
should support my friends cog and e and
nope they're uh they're all very
talented content creators
especially
our boy e who you know
is out here repping that advanced gg
hold the earth sauce he just he just he
just snorts it up a rolled up dollar
bill um and uh
i guess i guess uh cog you're now on
that hype too oh yeah he's pushing
powder yeah i'm pushing positive pushing
powder
you guys bought onto that so hard i've
seen the tweets already like pushing the
p or whatever like if we should be let's
go
push it better
again salute to dope for pulling up
absolutely hilarious anyone who can
bring the smoke with us and deal with
our foolishness is a fair i'm a fan of
automatically and she brought the 1v1 me
bro smoke with the trap which i did
enjoy
that was real i like that so that's cool
and uh yeah just uh
salute oh i got the uh
what you call the stream
going down so i gotta decide on a time
on saturday what i'm gonna do it but uh
stay tuned so everyone can see my misery
for a few hours you know in eldon ring
i'm gonna boot it up what are you doing
so maybe he'll make sure he likes me
he makes sure he gifted me so salute to
him
yeah everybody's gonna tune in for that
sunday will be iop iron lords come check
us out probably have um gwg grown women
gaming on that should be fun and again
check out defining duke my boy mr maddie
plays we've been rock and roll and
having a ton of fun hilarious topics
he's been killing it and that's on last
stand media network and of course looked
everybody that stayed around i know it
was a weird episode with the difficulty
with the technical stuff but we got
through it
and another last word in the books in my
opinion one of the best damn destiny
podcasts i'm just going to say it you
know we have a good time here
i will support that i think we have a
fun show there are also other very good
destiny shows yes shout out to mercury's
though um oh south tomorrow yes yeah
mercury's going to be i think he's going
to be a weapon designer or something he
already lives and breathes all that
stuff anyway and we had him on the
podcast a while ago but yeah the um
massive breakdown podcast is losing a
legend over there so he's going to be at
bungie and layman arc is now going to be
the meta so that'll be uh good i did not
know that yeah i did not know he got
hired
monday was i think monday was the start
i saw
i've seen quite a few people posting on
monday but mark was on monday so he was
about to merge
the fighting range no longer on massive
breakdown and uh yeah that was that was
a big one i'm allowed to do that for
sure nope yeah
i don't want to hear from my buddy cj
for like two years after yeah
he got real quick
yeah real quick
my fellow he's a symmetry user
absolutely yeah
well again thank you nope for showing up
i know it's like as i said like we've
talked off and on on kind of twitter and
keep in touch in the community and stuff
so glad to mix it up with you on the
podcast and yes if you can keep these
two hooligans in check it was amazing to
have you on because i need i need some
help sometimes so i appreciate it and
then i got thrown completely under the
bus with earth sauce so
it all ended quickly when that happened
and i'm just
waiting for the time that that shows up
in chat i guess we'll have to see but
for me uh
yeah we'll be posting a couple
yeah we'll be couple um yeah the fact
that most people didn't get to see this
live is probably gonna make it even more
interesting
um but yeah i'm gonna be playing elden
ring like till i can't sleep this
weekend that's all i'm gonna be doing
and posting up some stuff in between for
the channel but yeah i've got some time
to play about three straight days so
uh
and shout outs
hmm nice check out travis review
oh check out travis you're gonna you're
gonna love it do you like tabletop games
have you ever played like d or something
never
nice
that was in borderlands 2
borderlands 2 yeah yeah
yeah that was a that was a fun game yeah
it's basically just more of that it's
very it's very fun and the end game is
surprisingly there's some secrets i
don't want to give any spoilers away but
uh that end game activity let's just say
in the review period we found some stuff
that i think is going to surprise
players nice
that's
yeah i was like i checked
for sure
yeah
i mean he plays destiny too which i
would not describe as
like a relaxing game like destiny 2
especially raids could be raised i mean
it depends what you're doing if you just
run strikes and maybe it's relaxing i
would describe it as boring but i i
don't know
yeah you can see most most of destiny's
modes are pretty sweaty like that's yeah
i don't know
raids are sweaty dude rates are toxic
and he was day one out with his friends
i think he lost some friends that
yeah yeah yeah they're super fun
yeah
he's got to come in with the right
mindset that's
what it is and his friends didn't his
friends
mindset they yeah
shout out to iop
yeah my job is to be the comic relief
make sure everybody calm the hell down
and that's why that's right
yup yup
y'all remember my call outs
fallout had a hilarious call out video
too if you guys didn't catch that that
one's i don't want to get it i talk
about it oh go watch it it's like 20
minutes it's hilarious yeah he
absolutely how long ago he did it
yeah a few days just go to his channel
like recent videos it's like number
three or four it was like monday i think
or tuesday um but yeah that's that's
everybody so please go follow like
subscribe share all of these people's
content go to the ige interview hit
refresh a hundred times please go follow
nope when whatever she's streaming
whether it's tiny tina or eldon ring
please go support iron lord's podcast go
watch this man
uh hopefully not hate this game but you
know find one thing to love about it and
for me uh yeah it's destiny and elden
ring until
elden rings so eldering is going to
happen a lot
uh but for this episode number 190 crazy
numbers now been going for too long but
it's been amazing and uh yeah i think we
stayed on this thing a little too long
sorry travis hopefully you can go crash
on a preview
yeah
well thank you guys very much and as we
wrap it up here it has been
the last word